The joe rogan experience.
It's too hard for us to wrap our heads around how big the whole picture is.
You know,
when you realize that,
you know,
what does the,
um,
the,
the Woodstock song,
we are stardust.
We are golden.
We are billion year old carbon.
Well,
we were,
we really are.
Fucking Joni Mitchell.
Yeah.
Joni Mitchell.
And who was a Crosby stills.
They covered is eye what it was.
That's her song.
Yeah.
Brilliant Song.
And it's so true.
This is the thing that people do understand human beings actually made because
the star Burns out explodes.
And that has to happen.
If it doesn't happen,
you don't make those materials and human life,
carbon based life forms don't,
don't,
don't exist.
So even if it doesn't work out,
it works out.
Right.
You know,
you can understand and are in the state that we're in and you know,
this,
this real tactical,
tactical,
uh,
existence that we live,
you know,
you get caught up with the game,
you kind of get into the fear.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
and uh,
that's part of it.
Super easy.
So it's okay,
you know,
but,
uh,
every now and you get kind of wrapped up in it.
And,
uh,
I remember like last week,
the same guide to do Jitsu guy that I was telling you about Todd,
he,
uh,
he's,
he just out of the blue,
he texted me,
he's like,
so man,
how's it going?
Like,
it's almost like intuition.
Like how's it going?
Like funny you should ask because they've just been a shit storm the whole week.
And he goes,
Oh,
well let me just give you this.
And he sent me this.
I hope I brought it,
gives them this thing.
I ended up forwarding it to a bunch of people because I knew a bunch of other
people were going through some weird shit.
And uh,
may I,
sure a polluted.
So live your life that the fear of death can never enter your heart trouble.
No one about their religion,
respect others in their view and demand that they respect yours.
Love your life,
perfect your life,
beautify all things in your life.
Seek to make your life long and its purpose in the service of your people.
Prepare a noble death song for the day.
When you go over to the great divide,
always give a word or a sign of salute when meeting up or passing a friend,
even a stranger,
when an are lonely place,
show respect to all people and grovel to none.
When you arrived in the morning,
give thanks for the food,
for the joy of living.
If you see no reason for giving thanks.
The fault lies only in yourself.
Uh,
abused.
No one or no thing for abuse turns the wise ones into fools.
And Rob's a spirit of its division.
When it comes your time to die being out like those whose hearts are filled with
fear and death so that their time comes,
they weep.
They pray for more,
a little time and live their lives again over and over in a different way.
Instead,
sing near death song and die like a hero going home.
That's fucking beautiful.
So of course,
all my friends are like,
you know who wrote that?
So I had to go back to him.
I go,
where'd you get that?
He goes,
uh,
homeless do gave it to me.
Wow.
It's Jesus.
It's like,
please don't say it's l,
Ron Hubbard.
That would be my luck.
Like,
Oh,
you know Adolf Hitler.
Well,
it like,
I believe,
I appreciate that.
I actually found it online and it's um,
uh,
chief Tecumseh crouching tiger from the,
from the shiny nation.
Whoa.
He died in 18,
13.
Wow.
Yeah.
That makes it even more cool cause I thought it was some new age douchebag.
Probably do pilfered some stuff off the internet and pieced it together.
No,
that's perfect.
Yeah.
Wow.
I agree with everything you said.
Except for Megan.
Front of religion.
You go,
girl.
Other than that,
he's got me.
I think religion has to be made fun of because if you,
if you can't make fun of things that are ridiculous,
you're missing out on a big part of what's fun about this life and religions.
Ridiculous.
Respect it,
but made fun of it,
right?
Yeah.
Other than that,
I'm down.
I'm down with the Shawnee warriors.
I never knew,
I never knew how to start.
I don't hear anything Brian.